i've been quite open about this around
the office i don't want this parks
department to build any parks because i
don't believe in government i think that
all government
is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream
is to have the park system privatized
and run entirely for profit by
corporations
like chuck e cheese
they have an impeccable business model i
would rather work for chuck e cheese
thank you leslie
you're welcome ron
okay
time to go to work
laugh with me
buddy
just with me
buddy
don't let her get the best of me
buddy
don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
sir this this is a children's slide
you're not allowed to sleep in here you
know when i first tell people that i
work in the government they say oh the
government the government stinks the
lines are too long of the dmv but now
things have changed
people need our help
and it feels good to be needed could you
put your arms to your side
and that might help you slide down a
little easier you know do you want to
come this way oh oh okay we're going to
need you to get out get out of the slide
okay here we go okay please go away okay
wake up here we go out of the slide you
know government isn't just a boys club
anymore
women are
everywhere it's a great time to be a
woman in politics hillary clinton sarah
palin me nancy pelosi so i thank those
people
who've walked with me
and i thank you for this honor
now go find your team and get to work
in addition to governor knope's honorary
doctorate from the school of public
policy in recognition of all she's done
for the people of indiana the campus
library will henceforth bear her name
[Applause]
okay you need to understand that just to
keep this town afloat we probably have
to cut the budget of every department by
40 or 50 percent okay well but chris
said that you just had to you know
tinker with things yeah he said that
because that sounds a lot better than
we're going to gut it with a machete
[Laughter]
you're a jerk i'm sorry sorry these are
real people in a real town working in a
real building with real feelings
this building has feelings maybe there's
a lot of history in this one maybe it
does how can you be still blase because
i didn't cause these problems miss knope
your government did
i'll get what i need from the
spreadsheets thanks
what's a not gay way to ask him to go
camping with me
ben and i have an announcement leslie's
running for governor of indiana
[Applause]
only for you nope that's amazing yeah
she got approached by the dnc and they
think she has a great shot to win
indiana native supremely qualified and
she wrote that she wanted to be governor
in her kindergarten dream journal
just makes sense
this must be our hero
the man heard round the world uh-huh
how you doing son are you good
i'm leslie knope
and the
entire government of pawnee would like
to let you know that we will do
everything we can to help you
did you pass me my itch stick of course
bert macklin jr
we need a halloween angle how about
demons spawn baby satan dwyer oh i like
that yeah or
uh maybe bert snakehole
ludgate
karate dracula macklin demon
jack-o-lantern dwyer we call him jack
for short
i'm here
hey wow look at that safety you remember
tom from last night yeah how are you of
course i do and this is our college
intern april she's going to be
documenting our fact-finding mission
april hey it's just fun for you yeah
it's so much fun
hey oliver hey leslie
hello ann hi april your kids are like
surprisingly awesome thank you did you
use an egg donor or give chris a hall
pass for a night
once again they are my biological
children once again i don't believe you
hi hi i'm ann perkins uh
i'm a nurse and frankly i don't really
care for politics
uh
but um i'm i'm here to talk about the
abandoned lot on sullivan street
excellent that sounds like a good idea
tell us about that no it's a problem it
almost killed my boyfriend oh yeah
there's a lot nearby my house and a
developer dug out a basement for some
condos and then they went bankrupt so
there's just this giant pit
and it's been there for almost a year 12
months yes go on yeah and my boyfriend
who is a musician actually i support him
but anyway
he fell in and broke both his legs oh
it's a common misconception that the
oculus holds all of the power it's
actually the lamplighter and oh my god
it's happening it's totally happening
our kids are falling in love
this is good okay remember if this is
ever gonna work we have to pretend to
disapprove yeah right good call hey
i'll say no oh
who cares
hello hello oh hey how are you
hello there hi chris trager this is ben
hello gents ron swanson ron
swanson
okay
i'm deputy director leslie knope and
leslie
knope
it is fantastic to be here would you
gentlemen like a tour oh there is quite
literally nothing i would rather have in
the world than a tour of the parks and
recreation department of the great city
of pawnee led by ron swanson
and leslie knope
okay
ben i don't think that's a great idea
let's do it okay and you rainbow infused
space unicorn and you beautiful sassy
mannequin come to life and you
opalescent tree shark leslie you are the
master of the metaphor i recently
compared her to a nutrient-rich chia
seed
what's the thing on your wrist oh
you are extremely healthy
i do that literally 50 times a day
aren't you afraid that thing might give
you cancer
well i am now
well there he is
chip traeger you old son of a gun
andy it's chris
is it
huh uh i'm sure this must be really
tough for you you know just this guy
sounds like he didn't have a lot going
on for him to start with and now both
legs broken he's just weak you have to
take care of him you probably feel like
you need to move on
just become more adventurous in
relationships with your body just are
you are you actually hitting on me right
now
oh oh god no i'm not i'm not hitting on
you i'm actually married i'm just an
open person and i like connecting with
people i'm you know very comfortable
around women attractive women i've spent
a lot of time with them and i just i i
don't know i feel like we might be
taking up too much of the forum's time
maybe we can just exchange numbers
you know maybe go away one weekend and
just kind of talk about this look i'd
love to do it hey thanks so much for
coming guys are you kidding tom this is
incredible best-selling book a 40 city
tour well i couldn't have done it
without you well a book's called failure
i don't know how to take that i'm
serious you guys have always supported
me here i inscribed you a copy
when i think of success i think of you
you are a true inspiration to me i love
you tom haverford oh sorry that's
actually for kendrick lamar
here's yours
best wishes
i mean every word of it
you